hello ha sorry and welcome to this video
PK 15 ok hmm what do we play ok it's
going for the Catalan hmm check Carol
I'll stick with this against the Catalan
I have no real other option at the
moment that I can play and don't feel
comfortable with so I'm sticking with
them with the bow go check I think b6
was right here keep forgetting stuff
this is this is the right choice
delaying them yep waiting until 24 is
happening and um yeah probably you rook
c8 now 495 he can go be4 never that sir
that's a decent move yeah now i have d 5
i also have knight to e7 I think 97 is
some is a good choice ok hmm I wonder is
it kicking is he threatening to take one
f6 now maybe he is I mean it's not a big
issue but ok I think I can start with
this and go d5 next I'd like to play d 5
but the immediate one didn't really
didn't look that great so I'm going with
this now
yeah I want to do this 25 that looks
like the most solid option or the best
option I guess Queen takes Bishop takes
should just be equal yeah it's not super
exciting I have to admit it okay you're
okay I wonder what the ideas 23 maybe or
no well the ending should be ok for me
c6 square slightly weak but don't really
think it's a big issue it's also see for
that i can use myself
okay and let's see for didn't really
help that much yeah let's see for here
there's a form but so a for maybe not be
too it's not be to a movie on this that
probably doesn't do that much but at
least it feels annoying yeah I'm not
threatening to take a 4 here that much
this is a problem 93 however maybe for
Roxy form and possibly looks it too with
the night moves at some stage I forgot
about this actually it's a nice and easy
oh it's a simple move but he's at a
Scott knight c6 coming I beating away
five takes nights is six then a six is
not possible
hmm that's not so it's so great okay if
I take it knight c6 a six it's always
this be sick smooth hmm it's a bit of a
problem
hmm but 96's it's on the agenda anyway
okay I have to check it took too long
for that decision really dead so maybe
night to before here nine eight seven
rooks e7 p.m. it should be okay should
have just done that a lot quicker I
didn't see that move Knight a5 Wow ah
now I totally forgot that this is
possible I only looked at the a7 porn oh
my god oh now it's got f3 and we'll win
her stupid stuff can I am somehow fight
him gently not
that was very stupid didn't time what do
you think about that at all okay now
that was very stupid black resins didn't
didn't see that a five could have could
be taken as well ya hear this shouldn't
be a problem at all so what is fast yeah
Luke c2i I didn't dare to play that move
the beep on this is what the engine
wants to play what I had some I wasn't
really seeing how i stopped the pawn but
i have to check this is a point and i
can do here I still the beep on looked
too dangerous to me but yeah I think or
the engine gives that I can stop it and
this was the best continuation with her
with an advantage for black but I
couldn't really know yeah okay this
blunders look at 95 I was always
thinking about 9a seven which is freeing
the be born so this is I never looked at
95 so just I just blundered this yeah
looks it too is what I have to play he
replayed this far to risk le Roux k 1 is
keeping things equal after this yeah
Brooksie two is better for black play
again but I couldn't figure it out the
beep on as I said looked far too
dangerous for me before that I think the
game is some always about equal bishop
f6 is a is a strange and then taking is
somewhat strange ideas it's just very
young George after that and some
I was more expecting queen III or
something like that keeping the bishop
am this I think poses more problems for
black maybe something like this you know
it's a slight edge for white maybe the
way it done it happened there was simply
nothing going on but blundered route 85
95 yeah well this the thing is I was
also mostly looking at drupa chicks but
Knight takes stronger than just in time
just in time to catch the pawn I mean
it's not absolutely not clear that I can
win the game but and the only one
playing for a 44 win now that's that's
what I have to do okay thanks for
watching